l'odeur de chair en décomposition
imprègne la ville comme un brouillard
putride
les monceaux de cadavres empêchent
l'accès aux rues c'est comme si nous
étions à la veille du jour du jugement
dernier
will et là
je vais vous donner un conseil faites
vos affaires et partez tant que vous
pouvez encore
gelé croiser en ville de toujours elle
se comportait bizarrement je vous le dis
il n'y a qu'une seule explication
possible est la faire un pacte avec le
diable
si nous échappera pas essentielle
qu'est ce qui va marquer
ils vont essayer de briser
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait à nous tous
n'ayez pas peur mon enfant votre salut
est proche
[Musique]
il se passe des choses chez elle qui ne
sont vraiment pas l'être
[Musique]
hélas le diable en elle
ma volonté est plus forte que la vôtre
c'est scolaire
avouez
[Musique]
personne n'est à l'abri
[Applaudissements]
québec les oies
[Musique]
waouh
panini
c'est une force
bonne ou mauvaise
idée
[Musique]
chez les attaquants
cros
c'est un moment là
ouais
[Musique]
ok les gars on est venu pourquoi une
idée exacte maintenant activé ce truc
cette partie de vous que vous amener sur
le plateau je vous assure que ces gamins
ne sont pas prêts pour ce qu'il
s'apprête à voir
[Musique]
depuis la rue on nous appelait
bon les gars savent a semblé un peu
basique à certains ce qu'on a c'est 64
carré 32 pièces et que vous soyez riche
ou pauvre vous fassiez une école de la
vie ni de coupes à
l'échec tout le monde a sa chance
tournoi et en quelques jours il nous
faut quatre joueurs on va se qualifier
d' entre vraiment se poser la question
de si oui ou non on est impliqué dans ce
conseil soutient
les enfants
vous perdez vous devez quitter la zone
en perdra pas
conseil d'administration mais 400
dollars dans des ballons de foot mais
quand il s'agit de développement
intellectuel il refuse de les financer
[Musique]
des gosses comme ca issu de ce quartier
ne pourront jamais se payer ce concours
j'imagine qu'elle s'offre au nez
[Musique]
laissez tomber les et leurs parents les
laisser tomber le système scolaire aussi
mais c'est pas moi qui vais les laisser
tomber hockey
je crois que ce moment précis elle plus
heureux que j'ai connus de tous tu dis
ici vanter d'avoir gagné un trophée
william un vrai potentiel
[Musique]
attention le roi qui borde la route vers
saint soit ojito et moi on peut être
ultime de malades
[Musique]
le premier meurtre a eu lieu avant ma
naissance
on organisait une commémoration annuelle
le tueur se faisait appeler l'étrangleur
comment tuer longer le dossier du siège
via une manette en dessous pour moi il
n'était qu'une ombre du passé c'est quoi
ça tu as trouvé ça ou juste là
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour
wyler dépêche-toi des éléments amènent à
la une les bon appétit
ça c'est délicieux
[Musique]
je peux parler
cette photo n'était pas à moi on était
dans la voiture de mon père d'ailleurs
tu l'as vu paquet
tu fait fuir tous tes potes
ça vous insérez des noeuds ça vous
servira toute votre vie en famille comme
à l'extérieur
tu connais l'histoire de l'étrangleur
pourquoi tu te susic a tout d'un coup
[Musique]
je me trompe sûrement en mai
chez qui tue et des soi disant pour
étudier
je vécu avec lui toute ma vie j'aurai
remarqué des indices tu sais nos pères
ne nous disent pas tout
l'étrangleur
il a torturé à l'heure avec toi c'est
l'heure de resserrer nos liens fiston
tu l'as dit à quelqu'un
papa
des tees et crackers
6 et crackers je fais pas spitz et les
choses non mais tu as raison c'est pas
contre un sort d'une relation je
patiente pourra gérer
ça se passe mais un restaurant on paye
40 euros et on est traité comme de la
merde moi je voudrais comme de la merde
mais c'était comme ça
non enfin chaque mois
ce moment j'avais lâché mais tu sais
sophie l'amour c'est pas simplement sur
un pc dans les chiottes tu m'as dit
lionel alors jetez pas de gigoter habite
cet homme
du jeu c'est à chaque fois presque
même dans les chiottes bon
tu as déjà mis un coup de boule à
quelques ventes a fait avec le haut du
crâne tu vois je t'avais dit d'élan
alors attends c'est quoi les premiers
trucs à faire beaucoup
au niveau du salaire pour l'instant on
peut pas proposer autre chose que le
smic - au moins par contre ja de
prévenir que je suis un vrai connard
[Musique]
[Rires]
n'avait pas fait d'école d'art vous avez
quel âge
c'est trop tard et après vingt cinq ans
on va sur [ __ ]
un sextoy
[Rires]
[Musique]
plus d'une plus loger plus de matelas je
m'achète qu'a pété un câble
[Musique]
et plein de trucs tu vas voir
maintenant regain de ces captures va
voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où et aqua eyes conventionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tepco
[Musique]
heureusement
on la
[Musique]
connaît
daigneault et leader
[Musique]
here is here she will be still here you
que ça
il faudrait qu'elle sa culture
[Musique]